.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Ich bin auf der Suche nach dem Glück,
herzlich willkommen
zu "Reporter spezial", Elternglück.
Landläufig heisst es,
Kinder haben mache glücklich.
Aber stimmt das?
Das finden wir zusammen heraus.
* Perlende Klänge *
Zu Papa.
- So lange gewartet.
Ab Tag 1
des positiven Schwangerschaftstests
hat man Angst um die Kinder.
Ich mag lieber Fleisch.
Also, gute Fahrt.
Es ist Wüste und Paradies
gleichzeitig.
Kein Job war so hart
wie das Mamasein.
Die glücklichen Momente überwiegen.
Wir erleben viel Schönes.
Ich möchte es nicht anders.
Ich werde mein Bestes geben.
Ich als Mama, wir als Eltern.
Familie Rhyner
ist eine besondere Familie:
Lio und Sari sind Geschwister.
Mit ihren Eltern Sabina und Roger
sind die beiden
genetisch nicht verwandt,
obwohl Sabina ihre Kinder ausgetragen
und zur Welt gebracht hat.
Die beiden sind aus Samen-
und Eizellenspenden entstanden.
Meine erste Station
ist Familie Rhyner in Glaris.
Ich bin Mona.
- Freut mich, Sabina.
Hallo, Roger.
- Freut mich, Roger.
Und das ist Lio. Kannst du das auch?
Check. Klar. Und Sari.
Hoi, hoi.
- Wollen wir uns setzen?
Ich habe euch etwas mitgebracht.
Achtung.
Schau mal, das ist für dich.
- Wow.
Schaust du mal, was drin ist?
Danke.
Nein, noch ein Bagger.
Lio, öffne es doch erst einmal.
- "Nein, noch ein Bagger."
Das ist ein Stapler, Lio.
Aha, du hättest lieber
einen Traktor bekommen?
Ja. Mit Seitenmesser.
- Mit Seitenmesser.
Aha.
- Mit Rapidmesser.
Mit Rapidmesser.
Wir fragen: Machen Kinder glücklich?
Ja, sehr.
- Sehr?- Ja, sehr.
Es ist lässig mit ihnen.
Auch, wie sie die Welt sehen.
Die Kleinigkeiten.
Wir müssen das wieder kennenlernen.
Das vergisst man alles,
das ist sehr schön.
Bei euch war es nicht
selbstverständlich,
dass ihr jetzt hier
mit zwei Kindern sitzt.
Im Gegenteil.
Ich wollte immer vier Kinder.
Irgendwann war ich einfach froh
um das eine.
Sie war dann nur noch ein Bonus.
Ihr habt einiges auf euch genommen,
um die jetzige Familie zu sein.
Reporterin Helen Arnet
hat sie auf diesem Weg begleitet.
Hier sieht man die Küche,
das ist unsere Küche.
Das ist unser Wohnzimmer,
das Roger gezeichnet hat.
Das ganze Haus hat Roger gezeichnet.
Ein Mann, eine Frau, ein Haus -
eigentlich ideale Bedingungen
für die Gründung einer Familie.
Doch im oberen Stock des Hauses
klafft eine offene Wunde.
Und das wäre unser Kinderzimmer,
das leider noch leer steht.
Wie gross ist Ihr Kinderwunsch?
- Riesig.
Er ist wirklich riesig.
Man sieht es auch an der Wohnung, so
hätten wir kein Haus bauen müssen.
Das Ziel des Hauses war auch,
dass Kinder drin Platz haben.
Wir haben für die Zukunft gebaut
und wir haben mit Kindern gerechnet.
Und wir rechnen immer noch damit.
Nach ihrer Hochzeit
warteten die beiden
zwei Jahre vergeblich
auf eine Schwangerschaft.
Sabina Rhyner schien gesund,
man suchte die Gründe bei ihrem Mann.
Die Untersuchungen
gipfelten in der Vermutung,
Roger Rhyner leide an einem
Hirntumor, der ihn unfruchtbar mache.
Den wahren Grund erkannte man erst
nach mehreren Eizellenentnahmen
und In-vitro-Fertilisationen,
Befruchtungen im Reagenzglas also.
Dann haben wir ein Jahr probiert,
haben verschiedene Sachen
über uns ergehen lassen.
Du.- Nicht nur ich. Auch du.
Du hast dich auch operieren lassen.
Ja.
- Also, ja.
Die Ärzte sagten immer zu mir,
ich sei jung und gesund,
es stimme alles.
Aber ich wurde nie schwanger.
Dann fanden sie
bei der zweiten Punktion heraus,
dass meine Eier Klümpchen bilden.
Dadurch
kommt es zu 95 % zu Fehlgeburten
oder zu einem behinderten Kind.
Den beiden
blieben drei Möglichkeiten:
Kinderlosigkeit, Adoption
oder eine Reise nach Spanien,
wo Sabina Rhyner die Eizellen einer
fremden Frau implantiert würden,
befruchtet mit den Spermien
ihres Mannes Roger.
* Spanisches Radio *
Schätzungsweise 600 Schweizer Paare
unterziehen sich jedes Jahr
in Spanien
einer Fruchtbarkeitsbehandlung.
Die Hälfte davon
kommt in diese Klinik,
wo man sich auf eine deutschsprachige
Kundschaft spezialisiert hat.
Schönen Tag. Wie geht's?
- Hallo, sehr gut.
Zweimal wurde Sabina Rhyner
hier in Spanien
mit den Eizellen einer Spenderin
schwanger,
zweimal hat sie die Embryonen
in der Frühschwangerschaft verloren.
Ich hoffe, dass es dieses Mal
besser herauskommt.
Aber schwanger werde ich.
- Das ist schon mal gut.
Das sagte ich auch.
Ob es dieses,
das nächste oder übernächste wird -
Sie werden es schaffen.
So, jetzt kommt es direkt
aus dem Labor durch diese Schleuse,
die die Druckunterschiede
aufrecht erhält.
Frau Rhyner-Schmid, Sabina.
- Genau.
Zwei Embryonen.
Two.
Da liegen wir richtig.
Diese weisse Kugel da oben
ist das Tröpfchen,
wo die beiden Embryonen drin sind.
Dann gilt - wie Sie wissen -
nicht aufstehen, nicht bewegen.
Genau. 30 Min.
Ein paar Wochen gebärmutterkontrak-
tionsauslösende Dinge vermeiden.
Also keinen Sex, keinen Extremsport,
keine Unterwasseraktivität.
Alles andere können Sie machen.
Die Fruchtbarkeitsbehandlungen sind
belastend - für Körper und Psyche.
Bei der ersten hatte ich jeweils
auch Mühe, musste weinen und sagte:
"Nein, das kann ich nicht."
Mit der Zeit ist es aber peanuts.
Man macht es einfach.
Sie erhielten einen ganzen Sack
mit Medikamenten. Darf ich mal sehen?
Ja, sicher!
Das sind die Infusionen,
die ich machen muss.
Dann die Spritzen.
Dann die Pflaster.
Das sind Pflaster.
Das ist ... keine Ahnung!
Und das sind Vitamine.
Das ist eine Art Aspirin.
Die Arbeit der Reproduktionsmediziner
ist abgeschlossen.
Jetzt wird sich zeigen,
ob auch die Natur mitspielt.
Wie ist Ihr Gefühl? Kommt es gut?
- Ja, es kommt sehr gut.
Ich werde schwanger sein,
und es wird neun Monate in mir sein
und es wird gesund zur Welt kommen.
Der Embryonentransfer in Spanien
liegt zwei Wochen zurück.
Heute erfährt
die 28-jährige Sabina Rhyner,
ob sich
die befruchteten Spendereizellen
in ihrer Gebärmutter
eingenistet haben.
Ich bin angespannt
und kann es kaum mehr erwarten.
Welches Gefühl haben Sie?
Gemischt. Die letzten beiden Male,
als ich schwanger wurde,
hatte ich nie Bauchweh,
dieses Mal schon zwischendurch.
Das verunsichert mich etwas,
aber ich bin positiv eingestellt.
Wie schnell klopft Ihr Herz?
Sehr schnell!
V.a. habe ich nasse Hände,
wirklich schweissnasse Hände.
Hallo, Bea. Hier ist Sabina.
Ich rufe
wegen des Blutergebnisses an.
Oh. Weniger als zwei. Aha, okay.
Okay. Vielen Dank. Tschau, Bea.
Nein. Weniger als zwei,
das bedeutet:
keine Schwangerschaft.
Ich bin nicht schwanger.
Ja, mein Bauchgefühl
war doch richtig.
Nun denn!
* Schluchzen *
Drei Monate sind seit dem negativen
Schwangerschaftstest vergangen.
Im Haus von Sabina
und Roger Rhyner in Glarus
herrscht wieder Aufbruchsstimmung.
Am 4. fliegen.
- Und am 5. wieder zurück. Ja.
700 Fr.
- Boah. Okay, ja, easy.
Sie fliegen wieder nach Alicante -
mit welchen Plänen?
Für einen erneuten Transfer.
Oder?
- Neue Pläne.
Etwas Neues.
- Was?
Samen- und Eizellenspende.
Weil es jetzt schon zu oft
nicht geklappt hat,
so wie wir es gemacht haben.
Wir wollen etwas Neues probieren.
Wir haben neue Hoffnung geschöpft.
Dann hat das Kind genetisch
gar nichts mehr mit Ihnen zu tun.
Bis jetzt bestand ja noch die
Hoffnung, dass es Ihre Gene kriegt.
Wie ist das für Sie?
Ja, was soll ich sagen?
Wir haben uns schon lange
damit befasst.
Ich hatte einfach bis zuletzt
einen Funken Resthoffnung,
aber schlussendlich
spielt es keine Rolle.
Wir haben den Wunsch
und schon lange abgemacht,
wenn es so weit kommen sollte,
machen wir das.
Diese Spritze
habe ich schon gemacht.
War bisher für Sie
Adoption nie ein Thema?
Nicht konkret, nein.
Solange es diesen Weg gibt
und es für uns stimmt,
wie wir es besprochen haben,
ist das noch kein Thema.
Es wächst in ihr auf.
Das ist nochmals etwas anderes.
So sind wir auch
von Anfang an dabei.
Richtig.
- Das ist auch ...
Wenn ich jetzt z.B.
eine Zigarette anzünden würde,
dann habe ich das dem Kind angetan.
Was ich ...
Wenn jemand anders es austrägt,
weiss man nicht,
was sie alles gemacht hat.
Das ist ein Unterschied.
Einen Monat später reisen die beiden
zum vierten Mal nach Alicante.
Dort warten diese zwei
Embryonen auf den Transfer.
Entstanden sind sie
aus zwei Eizellen einer Spenderin
und einer Samenspende.
Kennenlernen wird das Kind
seine biologischen Eltern nie.
Spaniens Gesetz
schreibt die anonyme Spende vor.
Sechs Wochen später in Glarus.
Sabina Rhyner ist schwanger.
Heute steht der erste Ultraschall
auf dem Programm.
Zweimal schon hat sie die Kinder
in der Frühschwangerschaft verloren.
Du hast verschwitzte Hände.
- Ja.
Du bist nervöser als ich.
So, nicht erschrecken.
Da ist es ... das Kind.
Die positive Herzaktion.
Sehen Sie das?
- Es gibt Herztöne?
Ja, Herzaktion, hier. Sehen Sie das?
Ah ja, tatsächlich.
- Siehst du es?
Siehst du es nicht?
- Nein, es ist ...
Ich lege Ihnen kurz Farbe drauf.
Ah, okay.
Hier fliesst Blut.
Cool.
- Okay.
Es flimmert richtig schön. Super.
Es ist eine Riesenerleichterung.
Vielen Dank.
Man sieht schrecklich viel.
Nein, was ... Ja!
Das ist viel.
- Ja, das stimmt. Okay. Stimmt.
V.a. die Herztöne. Das ist super!
Nachs sechs Jahren Warten -
das Ende des langen Sehnens
rückt näher:
Die Geburt von Sabina Rhyners Sohn
steht kurz bevor.
Ich darf nicht zu oft zurückdenken,
denn manchmal macht es mich traurig,
wenn ich an diese Zeit denke.
Ich würde es wieder tun, aber
es war eine verdammt lange Zeit.
Ich freue mich, wenn ich ihn
in den Armen halten darf,
wenn er gesund ist,
und alles gut ist.
Sie haben viel auf sich genommen
für dieses Kind.
Ja, sehr.
- Wieso macht Sie das traurig?
Weil es so ...
Wie oft wurde ich
einfach nicht schwanger?
Ich machte den Transfer,
wurde aber nicht schwanger.
Wie oft hatte ich Schmerzen?
Ich habe es zweimal verloren.
Das geht nicht spurlos
an einem vorbei.
Darum schaue ich ungern zurück.
Ich schaue lieber nach vorne.
Wenn ich zurückschaue,
macht es mich traurig,
wenn ich nach vorne schaue,
glücklich.
* Babyweinen *
Es ist der 8. April 2015.
Der heilige Fridolin heisst
einen neuen Erdenbürger willkommen,
einen waschechten Glarner
mit spanischem Blut.
* Sanfte Musik *
So, zu Papa.
So lange gewartet.
Mama kommt.
Mama kommt. Bist du schon müde?
Hm? Es war streng, nicht wahr?
Ich bin glücklich.
Er kam um 14.16 Uhr zur Welt.
Der Moment,
als Lio in deinen Armen lag -
war das der schönste Tag
deines Lebens?
Ja, neben dem Tag
der Geburt der Tochter, Sari.
Das waren
die zwei schönsten Tage, ja.
Bei uns
sind Gabriela und Adrian Thomann.
Ihr seid
einen sehr ähnlichen Weg gegangen.
Auch ihr habt wie Rhyners
viel unternommen,
um schwanger zu werden,
ein Kind zu bekommen.
Aber bei euch hat es nicht geklappt.
Ihr seid kinderlos geblieben.
Als wir den Film geschaut haben, ist
euch bestimmt vieles hochgekommen.
Ja, die Emotionen sind hochgekommen.
Wir haben - oder ich zumindest
habe mitgelitten,
was sie auch durchgemacht haben.
Es war eine heftige Zeit damals.
Für mich war es der Horror.
Von Anfang an.
Das Neue erleben zu müssen,
dann diese Spritzerei,
die Hormone, von denen der Körper
fremdgesteuert wird.
Dann die ganzen Nebenwirkungen,
die ich hatte:
fast täglich Kopfschmerzen.
Keine Energie.
Für nichts Motivation.
Die anonyme Spermaabgabe
für uns Männer
und auf Kommando
alle diese Dinge machen ...
Das ist nicht lustig.
Das ist keine schöne Sache.
Diese Achterbahnfahrt,
dieses Auf und Ab
und wieder eine negative Nachricht.
Dann musste man sich
wieder motivieren,
hat sich positiv eingestellt.
Dann kam die nächste
negative Mitteilung,
dass es wieder nicht geklappt hat.
Ja, das war ...
... wirklich eine Achterbahnfahrt.
Und am Ende
eines auf den Deckel bekommen.
Das war ... Die Hoffnung ...
Dann stirbt die Hoffnung
innerhalb eines Sekundenbruchteils.
Was machte das mit der Beziehung?
Sie hat gelitten.
Ich glaube ...
ich darf hier sagen,
es hätte nicht mehr viel gebraucht,
bis unsere Beziehung
in die Brüche gegangen wäre.
Gott sei Dank
ging der Weg für uns positiv weiter.
Wir haben uns
auf einem guten Weg wieder gefunden.
Irgendwann muss man sich
damit auseinandersetzen,
dass es auch anders weitergehen
kann - auch ohne Kinder.
Gab es bei euch diesen Moment auch,
dass ihr gesagt habt:
"Das machen wir,
danach hören wir auf."
Wir haben darüber diskutiert:
"Was, wenn es wieder nicht klappt?"
"Machen wir weiter?"
Es geht nicht nur ums Machen,
sondern auch ums Bezahlen.
Ihr habt beide 100 % gearbeitet
und weitere Jobs angenommen,
um das bezahlen zu können.
Was haben euch am Ende
die Kinder gekostet?
Ein grosses Auto.
- Ein Riesenauto.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie teuer Autos sind.
Einen schönen Audi, sagen wir es so.
Als ich es ausrechnete,
musste ich weinen.
Ich dachte: "Du meine Güte,
wir haben so viel Geld gebraucht."
Ihr habt euch
vom Kinderwunsch verabschiedet.
Wann war bei euch der Moment,
als ihr gesagt habt: "Nun Plan B"?
Vor dem letzten Versuch sagten wir:
"Jetzt klappt es,
oder wir gehen auf Weltreise."
Das war ...
... wie ein Rettungsanker,
um diese negative Situation
überleben zu können.
Und ...
Als es klar war, dass wir
die Weltreise machen dürfen,
freuten wir uns darauf.
Mit dem ganzen Prozess vorher
hatten wir uns darauf eingestellt,
dass es wieder nicht klappen könnte.
Irgendwann muss man sich
damit auseinandersetzen,
dass es auch anders
weitergehen kann, auch ohne Kinder.
So einfach ist es definitiv nicht.
Das haben wir gesehen.
Aber wenn es klappt,
ist das Glück umso grösser.
Mit dem Kind kommt etwas anderes,
nämlich der Familienalltag.
Dieser Alltag sieht oft anders aus,
als die Fotos,
die man den Grosseltern schenkt,
um sie an die Wand zu hängen.
Oft wird das aber schöngeredet.
Aber wir haben drei Mama-Bloggerinnen
porträtiert, drei Mütter,
die sehr offen auch darüber reden:
über den Streit, den es gibt,
über Versagensängste
und auch die kleinen
oder grösseren Nervenzusammenbrüche.
Halt ihn fest.
Sitzt du hier?
Nein, ich habe gewinkt.
Vier Kinder - viermal glücklicher?
Ja.
Gute Frage.
Ähm ... Familie macht glücklich.
Die Anzahl?
Man wird nicht automatisch
glücklich mit Kindern.
Es kostet.
Man bezahlt
einen hohen Preis an Selbstaufgabe,
* Quengeln *
wofür man bereit sein muss.
Ja.
Aber wenn man es hat,
macht es glücklich. Meistens.
Er hat sich eines geschnappt.
- Oh, Entschuldigung.
Nein, nein, nein!
- Non! Ne touche pas les ...
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Die Vierfachmutter Nadine Chaignat
hat den Blog "Mamas unplugged"
ins Leben gerufen
und leitet die Plattform,
auf der Mütter und Väter Einblick
in ihren Familienalltag geben -
ungeschönt und schnörkellos.
Es ist nicht nur schön,
sondern es gibt viel Dreck.
Unter dem Tisch und überall.
Wir wollen zeigen: So ist es.
Es gibt viele Zuckerglücksmomente,
aber auch viele Momente,
in denen du am Boden
das Essen deiner Kinder einsammelst.
Es gehört beides dazu.
Da-da!
Was möchtest du denn gerne ...
essen?
* Babyweinen *
Das Baby hat bald genug.
Und unten, im unteren Stockwerk,
läuft ich weiss nicht was.
* Babyweinen *
Ah nein! Ich schaffe es nicht.
Man muss flexibel sein.
* Babyweinen *
* Kinderkreischen *
So wie immer. Brav.
Und jetzt?
- Jetzt sitzen wir hier.
Und warten, was passiert.
So.
- So?- Ja.
Das Krasseste am Kinderhaben
finde ich:
Bis zu einem gewissen Punkt
nehmen sie
eine unbesorgte Existenz.
Ab Tag 1
des positiven Schwangerschaftstests
hat man Angst um die Kinder.
Auch Sandra Casalini bloggt
in der "Schweizer Illustrierten"
über ihr Dasein als Mutter.
Unerwähnt: der Vater.
Im Familienalltag
sehr wohl präsent,
möchte er medial
nicht in Erscheinung treten.
Abgesehen davon
gewährt Sandra Casalini
den Leserinnen und Lesern
einen unverblümt-ehrlichen Einblick
ins Zusammenleben mit zwei Teenagern.
"Wenn ich
in zehn Jahren zurückblicke,
werde ich mich
auf die Dinge konzentrieren,
die ich nicht vermisse:
das Gemotze beim Aufstehen,
das Gemotze beim Essen,
das Gemotze über die Schule,
das Gemotze überhaupt."
"O mein Gott, ich bete drum,
dass sie nicht mehr
über alles und jeden motzen."
Wie findet ihr es,
dass Mama einen Blog schreibt
und in diesen Blogs über
eure Familiengeschichte schreibt?
Ich finde es lustig.
Ich lese mit,
ich weiss nicht, ob sie das weiss.
Doch.
- Okay, gut.
Gibst du Feedback?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Aber es ist interessant zu sehen,
was sie zu sagen hat.
Ich bin nicht einverstanden,
aber es ist okay.
Womit bist du nicht einverstanden?
- Es sind nicht deine Hasen.
Wer füttert sie?
- Ich. - Wenn du nicht da bist, ich.
Das wird gar nichts.
Auch wenn den Mama-Bloggerinnen
der Alltag als Vorlage dient:
Schreiben ist nicht immer einfach.
So, das war meine Mittagspause.
Ich dachte,
ich könne effizient arbeiten.
Ich habe es nicht so hingekriegt,
wie ich es wollte.
Er schläft nicht, immer noch nicht.
Ich lasse ihn etwas chillen
und hoffe,
noch etwas arbeiten zu können.
Wahrscheinlich
kommen gleich die anderen runter.
Das war mein Mittag. Hm.
Ich habe es geschafft,
in diesen 1 1/2 Std.,
eine einzige Mail zu schreiben.
* Quengeln *
Ja. Er schläft noch immer nicht.
Genau, diese Tüte
hat etwa 10 Min. hergehalten.
Immerhin,
dafür muss ich nun staubsaugen.
Es ist 6.30 Uhr. Nicht so
ganz meine Zeit, wie man sieht.
Aber der Wecker klingelt, weil
die Kinder um 7.30 Uhr Schule haben.
Guten Morgen.
Wir dürfen die Rollläden
nicht hochmachen,
weil Fakt ist:
Wenn man die Rollläden hochmacht,
werden Teenager blind.
Nicht wahr?
Und wenn ich hier reinkomme,
ist die Begeisterung immer ...
... extrem gross.
Denn hier sind diejenigen,
die mich am allerliebsten haben
im ganzen Haus.
Es ist Zeit aufzuwachen.
Hm.
- Gut geschlafen?
Natürlich könnten sie sich
selber den Wecker stellen,
aber der Gedanke ist deprimierend,
wenn sie morgens allein wursteln
und in die Schule trotten müssten,
ohne dass jemand Guten Morgen
gesagt hat.
Zack, zack, eins, zwei. Eins, zwei.
Ich ziehe noch kurz den Jingle rein.
Radiomoderatorin und Zweifachmutter
Evelyne Gutknecht
berichtet
in ihrem "Mamas unplugged"-Podcast
über den ganz normalen
Familienwahnsinn.
(Ab Band)
Wir lieben unsere Kinder heiss.
Und doch könnten wir sie oft
auf den Mond schiessen.
Aber das darf man nicht sagen.
In diesem Podcast schon.
Heute mit Janine und Evelyne. Hallo.
Jetzt kommt Kindermusik.
Er ist im Hüpfmodus.
Darf ich neben dir sitzen?
Ja genau, schliess die Äuglein.
Man kann sich nicht vorstellen,
was das Elternwerden mit einem macht
und wie man sich verändert.
Und dass man eine andere Mutter ist,
als man sich gedacht hat.
Ich dachte, ich werde unkompliziert.
Ich nähme die Kinde überall mit und
führe mein Leben weiter wie vorher.
Dann merkte ich,
dass ein Kind seinen Rhythmus hat
und nicht alles so macht,
wie man es gerne hätte.
Ich wurde sehr viel komplizierter.
Damit kannst du zum Tisch.
Oh nein, die gibt es nicht.
Evelyne Gutknecht und ihr Mann Peti
sind beide berufstätig:
er 80, sie 60 %.
Und noch einen Apfel.
Darf ich eines?
- Ja.- Oh, danke.
Jetzt gibt es noch Apfel.
- Wäk.
Was, "wäk"?
Wäk.
Zeig mal, ich prüfe,
ob es "wäk" ist.
Mhh!
Nein, du nicht Apfel.
Doch, das ist meiner
und das ist deiner.
Lustig ist:
Meine Ernährung ist ein Desaster.
Bevor wir Kinder hatten,
war für mich Gemüse ein No-Go.
Jetzt bringst du Apfel.
Nun ... Ja, es hat sich verändert.
Das ist auch etwas am Elternsein:
Man entdeckt neue Seiten an sich.
Es geht in die Fürsorge.
Man möchte, dass sie sich
einigermassen ausgewogen ernähren.
Also Essen ...
Das Essen ist eines der Themen,
das zuoberst
auf der Liste von Themen steht,
mit denen man sich
ab Tag 1 beschäftigt.
Also ... Was essen die Kinder?
Was essen sie nicht?
Und ... Es hört nicht auf.
Es hört nicht auf.
Ich mag lieber Fleisch.
- Aha.
Zu viel Fleisch ist ungesund.
Familie Chaignat.
Die Betreuung vierer Kleinkinder
braucht Power und Organisation.
Als wir das Elternprojekt
gestartet haben,
war ich mir nicht bewusst -
da kann ich ganz ehrlich sein -,
was es alles mit sich bringt.
(Quengelnd) Ich habe Hunger.
- Es ist bald so weit.
Was ist das Problem?
* Er spricht unverständlich. *
Ist Papa nicht dort? Wer ist dran?
Wir haben so viele davon.
David Chaignat,
der einen 100-%-Job hat,
packt daheim mit an.
Nadine managt die vier Kinder
und den Haushalt.
C'est beau, ça? Hein?
C'est beau, la roue?
Ich möchte wissen,
was ihr spielen wollt.
Wollt ihr damit spielen?
Seid vorsichtig. Spielt zusammen.
Geht ihr in Annas Zimmer?
Gibst du den Schoppen, Nadine?
- Du kannst ihn schon geben.
Aber eigentlich ...
Nein, mach doch du bitte die Küche,
mir stinkt's.
* Peti lacht. *
Du bist dir
der Permanenz nicht bewusst.
Das stimmt.
- Es mag viel leiden.
Wenn es mal anders läuft als geplant
oder man sich mal anstrengen muss,
geht es, aber nicht jeden Tag.
Die Tage beginnen teils um 5.30 Uhr,
und der Feierabend kommt nicht.
Wenn man um 22 Uhr
noch im Kinderzimmer steht ...
Das stimmt.
Man ist sich nicht bewusst,
welche Ausdauer man braucht,
weil niemand hinter dir steht
und übernehmen könnte.
Zeit für dich oder Zeit als Paar ...
... wird rar.
Und dann ... ja.
Hüpfen.
- Und jump!
Romantik hat keinen Platz mehr?
Doch.
- Sie hat Platz, aber es muss ...
Es ist geplanter als vorher,
würde ich sagen.
Aber wenn man es macht ...
Wir haben das Jahr
mit einem Tag gestartet,
an dem wir
allein in die Berge gingen.
Das hat gut getan.
Wir merkten, dass wir es
eigentlich gut zusammen haben.
Wir können es noch,
sind noch Freunde.
Ist dir langweilig?
Was könnte man dagegen machen?
- Keine Ahnung.
Hier gibt es viele rote.
Nein, die kannst du nicht essen.
Sonst bekommst du Bauchweh. Nein!
Dann musst du erbrechen.
Anna, möchtest du helfen?
- Ja.
Kinder haben
ist wie Achterbahnfahren.
Hochs und Tiefs und immer in Fahrt.
Die isst du noch.
Die Frage, ob sie glücklich machen -
es ist ein Glück nach unten.
Die eigenen Wurzeln werden gestärkt.
Das Erfüllende ... Über das Ganze
gesehen kann man mit Ja antworten.
Aber es ist kein
ein Ich-esse-ein-Glace-Glück.
Wenn man abends um 21 Uhr
im Kinderzimmer sitzt
und die Situation heute mit
vor sieben Jahren vergleicht ...
Wenn man ständig irgendwo anders
sein möchte als im Kinderzimmer,
ist man unglücklich.
Man muss sich entscheiden: Es ist
gut, wo ich bin, das ist mein Platz.
* Vereinzelte verspielte Klänge *
Schlafmangel, keine Zeit für die
Beziehung oder eigene Bedürfnisse,
dafür ständig Diskussionen
wegen des Aufräumens,
des Gamens und der Aufgaben.
Wenn die Kinder abends
aber im Bett liegen,
geht einem das Herz auf.
Überwiegt am Ende immer das Glück?
Diese Frage stelle Glücksforscher
und Professor für Volkswirtschaft,
Mathias Binswanger.
Oft ist es so, dass Kinder
zunächst einmal glücklich machen.
Man freut sich auf ein Kind.
Zeitlich verzögert sieht man, dass
man das ganze Leben umstellen muss.
Das sorgt für etwas weniger Glück.
Das Glück nimmt ab.
- Es nimmt vielleicht ab.
Dann ist es oft so, dass es sehr
stark von den Umständen abhängt.
Also:
Lebt man in familiären Umständen,
die es einfach machen,
mit Kindern zu leben?
Dann sind die Kinder
ein Glücksfaktor.
Wenn man aber in Umständen lebt,
in denen Kinder zu integrieren
schwierig ist,
sind sie eher Unglücksfaktor.
Welches Familienmodell
macht am wenigsten glücklich
im Zusammenhang mit dem Kinderhaben?
Familienmodelle, die im Alltag
mit Stress verbunden sind,
machen nicht glücklich.
Aber auch mit Stress finanzieller
Art, den es auch gibt mit Kindern.
Eine alleinerziehende Mutter
mit Kindern
ist die Familienform,
die am wenigsten glücklich macht,
weil sie mit viel Stress
verbunden ist.
Aber auch Doppelverdiener-Familien
mit Kindern,
wo sowohl Mann als auch Frau
100 % arbeiten.
Das ist in vielen Fällen auch keine
glückbringende Form des Lebens,
weil das
zu einem gestressten Alltag führt,
in dem man von morgens bis abends
knallhart planen muss.
Man muss die Kinder bringen
und holen und dazwischen zur Arbeit.
Das führt zu solchen Horrorstorys
Tag für Tag.
Es gibt Untersuchungen
von Soziologen,
die das genau angeschaut haben.
Wenn man das liest,
hat man das Gefühl,
das sei kein lustiges Leben.
Wenn man Kinder hat,
ist man statistisch gesehen
unglücklicher als ohne Kinder?
Ja, z.B. können Kinderlose
spontan verreisen.
Sie können abends etwas unternehmen.
Selber kann man nicht,
weil die Kinder da sind.
Man muss sich um sie kümmern,
mühsam Babysitter suchen.
Da können die anderen in gewissen
Momenten glücklicher sein.
* Verspielte Klänge *
Laut Glücksforscher
Mathias Binswanger
sind Kinder
nicht das grosse Los zum Glück.
Und doch sagen in der Schweiz
90 % aller 20- bis 29-Jährigen:
"Ich will Kinder."
Das macht aus jenen, die sich
bewusst gegen Kinder entscheiden,
so etwas wie Exoten
in unserer Gesellschaft.
Wie lebt man damit? Und lebt man so
vielleicht glücklicher?
Sie haben sich bewusst
gegen Kinder entschieden.
Ich bin Mona. Freut mich sehr.
Moritz, Mona.
- Hoi, Mona.
Moritz Wittensöldner und
seine Lebenspartnerin Regula Simon.
Die Primarlehrerin gibt Workshops
zum Thema Kinderlosigkeit,
begleitet und vernetzt
betroffene Frauen.
Romina Buica ist Französischlehrerin
an einem Gymnasium.
Die 38-Jährige mag Kinder, verzichtet
aber bewusst auf eigenen Nachwuchs.
Ich hatte den Wunsch
einfach noch nie.
Ich weiss inzwischen,
dass die meisten Menschen ihn haben.
Es verunsichert mich auch,
den Wunsch nicht zu haben.
Aber er ist bisher
noch nicht aufgetreten.
Das hat sich nie geändert?
- Nein, bisher nicht.
Als ich mit 22 sagte,
das interessiere mich nicht
oder es gibt einfach
noch so viele andere Dinge,
die mich interessieren ...
Jetzt bin ich 38,
und es gibt immer noch viele Dinge,
die ich vorher lieber machen möchte,
als Kinder zu haben.
Das Narrativ kenne ich schon:
"Das kommt noch."
Ehrlich gesagt warte ich immer noch.
Vielleicht kommt es auch.
Aber dann bin ich vielleicht 65.
Das kann ich nicht ausschliessen.
Ihr seid nicht kinderlos,
sondern kinderfrei.
Was ist der Unterschied
zwischen kinderlos und kinderfrei?
Kinderlos ist defizitorientiert.
D.h., es fehlt etwas,
etwas ist falsch.
Kinderfrei heisst,
es ist eine freie Entscheidung.
"Ich habe das nicht,
bin damit aber nicht unglücklich."
Kinderfrei zu sein
ist dein freier Entscheid.
Worauf müsstest du verzichten,
wenn du Kinder hättest?
Vielleicht darauf,
was potenziell möglich wäre.
Nämlich:
An einem Dienstagabend zu wissen,
ich könnte zu Hause bleiben
und am Roman weiterlesen,
den ich gerne weiterlesen möchte.
Ich könnte auch die Wäsche machen
oder rausgehen und Tango tanzen.
Niemand schreibt mir das vor.
Ich schätze diese Zeit,
in der mich niemand braucht.
Aber ich schätze auch die Zeit,
in der mich jemand braucht.
Ich unterrichte sehr gerne
an einer grossen Schule.
Es ist wie ein Bienenhaus,
ich bin eine der aktiven Bienen.
Im Gang wird oft gerufen:
"Hey, Romina. Und überhaupt ..."
Aber dann mag ich auch den Freiraum,
wenn das niemand tut.
Bei dir, Regula, ist das anders.
Bei dir wurde es erst um die 40 klar,
dass du keine Kinder haben wirst,
nämlich als du Moritz
kennengelernt hast.
Er kam mit einer klaren Ansage,
ich zitiere:
"Ich möchte keine Kinder."
Du hattest bis dahin noch keine.
Was dachtest du,
als er das so klar kommunizierte?
Im ersten Moment ...
... erschrak ich.
Ich hatte immer das Gefühl,
dass ich Kinder haben würde.
Wenn dann wirklich ein Mann kommt,
mit dem ich mir das
vorstellen könnte ...
Er war so einer, mit dem ich
es mir vorstellen konnte,
das war eine solide Beziehung.
Mit ihm würde ein solch
schwieriges Projekt funktionieren.
Aber er sagte:
"Nein, kommt nicht infrage."
Im ersten Moment war das ... Okay.
Aber - und das habe ich
später herausgefunden -
für mich hatte das
eine ganz andere Bedeutung.
Wenn ich z.B. eine Frau
mit Kinderwagen
oder eine Schwangere sah,
zog ich in meinem Unterbewusstsein
den Schluss:
"Sie hat einen Mann,
der voll und ganz zu ihr steht."
Als der Mann,
den ich gefunden hatte,
sagte, er wolle keine Kinder,
stellte sich für mich die Frage:
"Will er mich,
will er eine Zukunft mit mir?"
Warst du damals traurig oder wütend?
Verunsichert.
Ich fand dann heraus, dass
die Vorstellung, Kinder zu haben
gar nicht so verlockend war.
Als Teenager wollte ich
eigentlich nie erwachsen werden.
Rückblickend
hat es wohl damit zu tun,
dass ich mitbekommen hatte,
dass Muttersein
sehr anstrengend ist.
Das stimmt.
- Eben.
Ich hatte auch das Gefühl:
Wenn man erwachsen ist,
ist das Leben fertig,
nicht mehr lustig.
Seit wann weisst du,
dass du keine Kinder willst?
Das habe ich vielleicht
in der Pubertät herausgefunden.
Ich habe mir überlegt,
was das bedeutet.
Ja.
Und dass dies
mein Leben einschränken würde.
Ich bin sehr freiheitsliebend,
unabhängig.
Das würde mich 20 Jahre lang
verfolgen, besetzen oder fesseln.
So fühlte es sich für mich an.
Du sahst v.a. das Negative.
Später hattest du sicher Freunde,
die Vater geworden sind.
Wechselt die Perspektive
nicht irgendwann?
Nein, sie bestätigen mir
meine Vorurteile.
Das Schöne sehe ich schon.
Ich komme zu Besuch, spiele
mit den Kindern und gehe wieder.
Aber die Väter müssen bleiben.
Dann tun sie mir leid.
Sicher?
- Ja.
Das würde mich überfordern. Dieser
Aufgabe bin ich nicht gewachsen.
Umfeld und Gesellschaft erwarten
eine Familie, v.a. von einer Frau.
In welchen Situationen spürst du das?
Z.B. in klassischen
Vorstellungsrunden.
"Was machst denn du?"
"Aha, Lehrerin."
"Arbeitest du Teilzeit?"
"Ja."
"Weil du Kinder hast?"
"Nein."
Die meisten Menschen
sind dann vorsichtig.
Vorsichtig?
- Ja.
Menschen,
die einem ins Gesicht sagen:
"Ui, du hast keine Kinder."
"Das finde ich egoistisch."
Das ist ganz selten.
Wenn man sagt,
man habe keine Kinder,
fragt sich der andere immer,
ob er Mitleid haben müsse,
weil sie keine haben kann,
oder ist sie böse und will keine.
Erlebst du das auch so? Du lachst.
Ja, total.
Es ist eine Mischung zwischen:
"Ist sie eine Arme oder komisch?"
Dann sage ich jeweils schnell:
"Nein, ich bin komisch.
Keine Sorge."
Wer gerne Kinder gehabt hätte, aber
keine haben kann, bekommt Mitleid.
Die anderen hören den Vorwurf,
man sei egoistisch
und wolle
keine Verantwortung übernehmen.
Wer Kinder will und ehrlich ist,
ist auch egoistisch.
Eine Frage, die ich
ganz selten zu stellen getraue, ist:
Unter Freundinnen
gibt es den Moment, wenn eine sagt,
sie sei schwanger.
Das ist ein heikler Moment,
weil man richtig reagieren muss.
In solchen Momenten ...
... würde ich gerne fragen:
"Warum möchtest du das?"
Wenn ich mich selber frage,
warum man Kinder haben möchte,
gibt es die Antwort,
man wolle seine Gene verbreiten.
Es gibt die Komponente
Unsterblichkeit.
Nicht allein sein.
Umgeben sein von meinesgleichen,
von meinem Fleisch und Blut.
Diese drei Gründe sind
durchaus egoistische Gründe.
Egoistisch nicht
im moralisch abwertenden Sinn.
Aber Gründe, die mich
auf mich selber zurückwerfen,
darauf, was ich möchte.
Die Vorstellung, man könnte es
bereuen, wenn man älter wird,
oder dass man allein sein wird -
kommt die manchmal?
Nein.
Im Alter ist man sowieso einsam.
Das ist unausweichlich.
Das ist einfach so.
Dadurch dass man
viele Freundschaften knüpft,
Kontakte pflegt,
kann man es vielleicht ...
... ein bisschen hinauszögern.
Man kann das soziale Netz
verbessern.
Diese Chance
haben wir als Kinderlose eher.
Man muss sich diese Menschen aktiv
suchen, Freundschaften pflegen,
damit man dieses Umfeld hat.
Mir sagte kürzlich
eine 80-jährige Mutter,
die Kinder hat,
die sie ab und zu besuchen,
dass sie sich
auch um Kontakte bemühen muss.
Nicht nur mit den Kindern,
sondern auch mit anderen Menschen.
Das Umfeld zu gestalten
ist meine Entscheidung,
unabhängig von Kindern.
Vielen Dank fürs Vorbeikommen.
Kinder haben oder nicht -
es ist eine Entscheidung.
Diese kann man aber auch bereuen.
In einer anonymen Umfrage
in Deutschland
sagten - erstaunlicherweise -
20 % der Eltern,
dass sie sich
gegen Kinder entschieden hätten,
wenn sie gewusst hätten,
was auf sie zukommt.
Laut Glücksforscher
Mathias Binswanger
sinkt z.B. bei den Alleinerziehenden
die Glückskurve in den Keller.
Wir haben zwei Frauen porträtiert,
die dieses Tabu brechen
und offen dazu stehen,
dass sie die Mutterrolle wider
Erwarten unglücklich gemacht habe.
Wenn ich wüsste, dass ich in genau
dieser Situation landen würde,
in der ich jetzt stecke,
mit der Erschöpfung,
die es mit sich bringt,
und nicht mehr selber
bestimmen können, was ich möchte -
das dauert ja schon an,
seit er auf der Welt ist -
ganz ehrlich: nein.
Würden Sie kein Kind mehr machen?
- Nein.
Der tägliche Spagat zwischen
Kindererziehung, Haushalt und Job.
Das Pensum
der alleinerziehenden Mutter
und Sek-Lehrerin Daniela Segmüller
ist kräftezehrend.
Habe ich gesehen.
- Hast du gesehen?
Hier und hier für den Dance-Mix.
Muss man sich
für die Kurse anmelden?
Was ist das? Der Webrahmen?
Komm.
Alles ausziehen.
Seit Noés Geburt
ist Daniela Segmüller
quasi allein für das Wohl des
heute Sechsjährigen verantwortlich.
Der Druck, ihm alles zu bieten,
lässt sie häufig
an der Mutterrolle zweifeln.
Das heisst überhaupt nicht,
dass ich ihn nicht liebe.
Ich liebe ihn über alles.
Aber mit allen Konsequenzen,
die es mit sich bringt,
kann man es nicht schönreden.
Es ist nicht schön, schlaflos in
der totalen Erschöpfung zu landen.
Im Job dauernd hinterher zu rennen.
Ganz ehrlich, ich finde nicht,
dass das die Erfüllung ist.
Das darf man auch mal sagen.
Aber es fällt Ihnen schwer.
- Natürlich.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
eine schlechte Mutter zu sein.
Es ist ein Tabuthema,
über das niemand spricht.
Es hat sich noch niemand getraut.
Es kommt immer mehr.
Es ist unschön, darüber zu reden.
Aber am Ende ist es etwas Gutes.
Hm? Zeig mal.
Du hast gar kein Pipi gemacht.
Noëmi Schöni: Unternehmerin,
Mutter der dreijährigen Nyavel.
Nyavel ist ein Wunschkind.
Doch nach der Geburt
schlitterte Noëmi Schöni
in eine postpartale Depression,
die nicht behandelt wurde
und schliesslich
in einem Burn-out gipfelte.
Kurz darauf ging Noëmi Schönis Ehe
in die Brüche.
Seither ist die 35-Jährige
alleinerziehend.
Mein Tag
beginnt schon völlig gestresst.
Es ist selten,
dass sie einfach kommt und macht.
Es ist immer ein Bearbeiten,
Überzeugen und ja ...
Irgendwann fragt man sich,
warum, wieso und für was,
was das soll.
Was haben Sie morgens für Gedanken?
Warum stehen Sie auf?
Ja ...
Eigentlich weil ich muss. Ich muss.
Ich muss mein Kind versorgen,
Geld verdienen ...
Und die Kombination von beidem in
einer sehr hohen Leistungsform ...
Ich hatte sehr viele anspruchsvolle
Jobs mit viel Verantwortung.
Aber kein Job war so hart
wie das Mamasein.
Ist gut.
Ab die Post.
Haben wir alles?
Portemonnaie, Schlüssel.
Sonnenhut haben wir.
So.
Auch Daniela Segmüller
hat das Muttersein unterschätzt.
Zwar unterstützt Noés Vater
sie mittlerweile,
doch die Verantwortung
und die Hauptlast des Alltags
trägt die Mutter.
Du hast einen Schnabel.
Brauchst du den Lappen?
Finger putzen.
- Nein.
Ich bin die Mama und der Papa.
Die Rolle, die sonst
auf zwei Leute aufgeteilt ist,
kompensiere ich in einer Person,
und zwar jeden Tag.
Ich gehe um 8 Uhr, wenn er geht,
und komme um 17 Uhr.
Dann geht es nahtlos weiter,
bis er im Bett ist.
Und zwar voll und ohne Pause.
Du?
Hm?- Sitzt du anständig
auf den Tripptrapp?
Nein.
- Komm.
Irgendwann poltert es,
und wer liegt dann unter dem Tisch?
Du?
- Nein, ich glaube nicht.
So, fertig.
Sag: "Guten Morgen, Valentina."
Noëmi Schöni
hat eine eigene Beratungsfirma
für digitale Marketingstrategien.
Ihre Tage sind lang und richten sich
nach den Bedürfnissen ihrer Kunden.
Ihre Eltern sind noch berufstätig
und wohnen weit weg.
Einen bis zwei Tage pro Woche
bringt Noëmi Schöni
ihre Tochter darum in eine Kita.
Also, Mäuschen. Schätzchen,
ich wünsche dir einen schönen Tag.
Ich habe in meinem Leben
viel geleistet.
Es gab schwierige Situationen,
grosse Herausforderungen.
Ja, das habe ich ... gemeistert.
Beim Muttersein
und geschäftlich erfolgreich sein
bin ich kläglich gescheitert.
Ich bin keine Mutter, die sagt,
ein Lächeln pro Tag entschädige mich
für die geleistete Arbeit,
die auf mich genommenen Schmerzen.
Sondern ich finde:
Ich habe keine Energie mehr.
Ich brauche etwas,
das mir etwas gibt,
oder mehr solcher Momente.
Die Momente geben einem schon etwas,
aber das Verhältnis
des energetischen Investments
ist so viel grösser,
als was zurückkommt.
Es ändert sich vielleicht noch.
Ein kleines Kind kann noch nicht
so interagieren wie ein grösseres.
Vielleicht finde ich es
in ein, zwei Jahren auch mega cool.
Es gibt erst seit ein paar Monaten
Tage, an denen ich sage:
Mamasein kann cool sein.
Ich liebe meine Tochter, aber
das scheint mir nicht zu reichen.
Ich bin sehr dankbar,
dass es jetzt solche Tage gibt
und ich hoffe,
dass sie häufiger vorkommen.
Komm, du kannst auch.
Yeah.
- Machst du mit?
Ja.
- Also, komm.
Ich zehn und du zehn?
- Ja.
Vielleicht schaffe ich auch mehr.
Hinstehen.
- So?- Ja.
Genau. Eins.
Zwei.
Drei.
- Anspannen.
Nicht so fest. Nein, nein, nein.
Ich bin sehr selbstbestimmend,
freiheitsliebend
und habe
einen grossen Bewegungsdrang.
Diesen kann ich mit Noé
gut kompensieren.
Wir gehen raus, das ist super.
Er ist wie ich.
Aber ich kann nicht mehr
nach Lust und Laune ... zum Sport.
Wenn ich zum Sport gehe,
muss jemand auf ihn aufpassen.
Ich muss fragen:
"Kann ich dir Noé bringen?"
Ich muss mich dann
aber immer rechtfertigen,
warum ich mein Kind abgebe.
Das klingt so böse:
Ich will mein Kind abgeben.
Aber ich bin ja auch noch da.
Schickst du mir den Ball zurück?
Mit der anderen Hand.
Schaffst du es mit der anderen? Hey!
Wenn es nicht geht,
auf die Knie gehen.
Seit Trennung von Noés Vater
vor gut sechs Jahren
lebt Daniela Segmüller ohne Partner.
Es ist einsam, ja.
Es gab Phasen in meinem Leben,
als Noé noch ganz klein war,
in denen ich wochenlang
mit niemandem redete.
Es gab Sandkasten-Gespräche,
in denen man
über Windeln und Brei spricht.
Aber nicht: "Wie geht es dir?"
Menschen, die mich fragen,
wie es mir geht, gibt es nur wenige.
Die kann ich an einer Hand abzählen.
(Mann ab Band) Pumuckl
hat einen neuen Spielplatz entdeckt.
Einmal hoch.
Mit den Jahren
hat Daniela Segmüller gelernt,
sich Auszeiten zu gönnen.
Noch sind diese selten,
doch je älter Noé wird, umso grösser
dürfte der eigene Freiraum werden.
Hinlegen.
(Mann ab Band)
Warum möchtest du das wissen?
Ich mag mein Kind, aber ...
... wenn ich noch einmal
entscheiden könnte,
Mutter oder Vater zu werden,
würde ich es nicht mehr machen.
Eine krasse Aussage,
die wir nun diskutieren.
Bei mir sind Andrea Borzatta,
Präsidentin des Vereins
Postpartale Depression Schweiz,
und Egon Garstick,
Psychotherapeut, Paartherapeut,
der mit vielen Familien arbeitet,
bei denen es um dieses Thema geht.
Ihr Buch heisst:
"Junge Väter in seelischen Krisen".
Eltern werden
und sich eingestehen müssen,
dass das Glück
gar nicht so gross ist:
Erleben Sie das oft,
dass Menschen Ihnen das sagen?
Das ist ein wichtiges Thema
in unserer Gesellschaft,
das tabuisiert wird.
Man darf
widersprüchliche Gefühle haben,
auch während der Schwangerschaft
und nach der Geburt.
Paare brauchen ein Umfeld,
in dem man so was mitteilen darf.
Dass man nicht nur
glücklich darüber ist -
obwohl das Kind gewollt war -
und nicht nur total befriedigt ist,
sondern dass vieles anders geworden
ist und man etwas vermisst.
Eigene Hobbys können z.B. nicht mehr
so intensiv ausgelebt werden.
Man muss vorübergehend
beruflich zurückstecken.
Das sind Beeinträchtigungen,
die einem davon abbringen können,
glücklich zu sein.
Wir haben
zwei alleinerziehende Frauen gesehen.
Ist alleinerziehend zu sein
ein Faktor,
dass Elternschaft als besonders
mühsam oder schwierig empfunden wird?
Diese beiden Frauen
sind wirklich allein
mit der Aufgabe,
für ihr Kind zu sorgen.
Und - das war deutlich -
es waren zwei Frauen,
die Lust an ihrem Beruf haben,
das ist auch richtig so.
Das kommt dann alles zu kurz.
Da braucht's Solidarität.
Wenn es der Partner
nicht geben kann,
sollten Verwandte,
Grosseltern da sein,
die das unterstützen:
"Mach du deinen Job weiter,
wir helfen dir,
damit du erfolgreich und zufrieden
als Mutter und Berufsfrau
sein kannst."
Wenn man sagt, Elternsein
mache einen nicht glücklich,
offen dazu zu stehen,
braucht sehr viel Mut.
Wie sehen Sie das?
Das glaube ich auch.
Wenn man mich heute fragen würde,
würde ich sagen:
Es macht mich glücklich,
ich bin stolz auf meine zwei Jungs.
Aber wenn man mich im ersten Jahr
nach der Geburt gefragt hätte,
bin ich ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher.
Wie sehen diese Gefühle aus? Wie muss
man sich die Ambivalenz vorstellen?
Die meisten Frauen
kennen den Babyblues.
Das vergeht ja wieder.
Wenn es länger
als zwei Wochen andauert,
muss man es genauer anschauen.
Bei mir waren diese Gefühle
im ersten Jahr
v.a. durch Ängste geprägt.
Ich fühlte mich innerlich leer,
ich hatte kein Interesse,
etwas zu machen,
ich zog mich sozial
sehr stark zurück.
Ich liess aber auch niemanden
an mich ran.
Bei Frauen kennt man die postpartale
oder postnatale Depression.
Das ist eine Diagnose.
Gibt es das bei Vätern auch?
Das wurde lange
gar nicht richtig erkannt.
Mittlerweile wissen wir,
dass es das gibt.
Studien belegen, dass auch Väter
eine depressive Verstimmung
haben können.
Das sog. Bindungshormon,
das dann mehr entwickelt wird,
sorgt dafür, das vorübergehend
das typisch männliche Hormon,
das Testosteron, zurückgeht.
Das kann einige Männer verwirren
und in Schwierigkeiten bringen.
Und auch die Beziehung.
Wie kommt man aus einer Krise raus?
Angenommen man leidet
unter einer postpartalen Depression
oder erlebt eine Krise, weil sich
das Leben total verändert hat
und man nicht weiss,
ob einem das neue gefällt.
Wie erholt man sich davon?
Ich habe gemerkt, dass es oft hilft,
wenn man schwarz auf weiss
etwas hat.
Es klingt doof, aber es gibt
einfache Tests mit einer Skala,
die man machen kann,
ein Fragebogen mit zehn Fragen.
Man bekommt eine Punktzahl.
Es ist keine Diagnose.
Aber es hilft zu erkennen,
dass man fachliche Hilfe braucht.
Manchmal hilft auch, wenn einem das
jemand von aussen weitergibt.
Auch nicht Angst davor haben,
was die andere denken könnte,
wenn man über das Thema redet.
Das gilt auch für Fachpersonen.
- Ja.
So viele Fachpersonen
sprechen es nicht an.
Sechs bis acht Wochen nach
der Geburt geht man zum Gynäkologen.
Dieser schaut,
ob körperlich alles in Ordnung ist.
Aber nicht,
wie es der Frau psychisch geht.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt
wäre ein solcher Test sinnvoll.
Der Gynäkologe muss nicht direkt
der heulenden Patientin helfen.
Er muss wissen,
wohin er sie verweisen kann.
Wer auch Hilfe braucht,
ist das Baby.
Wird eine postpartale Depression
nicht behandelt,
ist das nicht nur
für die Mutter schlecht,
sondern auch für das Kind.
Es sieht zu lange
ein nicht-lebendiges Gesicht.
Eltern werden -
man stellt es sich vor,
aber meist ist es
in Realität ganz anders.
Es ist sozusagen ein Wendepunkt.
Ja, es ist eine Hilfe,
um etwas ganz Wesentliches,
das für uns Menschen wichtig ist,
in den Griff zu bekommen:
die Vergänglichkeit zu akzeptieren.
Ein Kind zu haben,
es zu einem Erwachsenen zu erziehen,
kann wie eine Kompensation sein.
Es kann helfen, den eigenen Tod
besser zu verkraften.
Wenn ich ein Kind mitverfolgen darf,
wie es seinen Weg geht,
und ich dazu beigetragen habe,
dass es klappt,
kann mich das trösten,
das eigene Sterben zu verkraften.
Ich rede
aus der Grossvaterperspektive.
Die Wissenschaft sagt,
Kinder machen glücklich,
wenn sie ausgezogen sind. Stimmt das?
Auch em sind wir nachgegangen
und haben Brigitte
und Walter Hollenstein getroffen.
Sie haben vier Kinder grossgezogen
und sind Grosseltern von zehn Enkeln.
Wie sie es erleben,
auch rückblickend, sehen wir uns an.
Das gibt eine tolle Autobahn.
Doch, das ist schon gut.
Geht das,
wenn wir so enge Kurven machen?
Walter und Brigtte Hollenstein
sind leidenschaftliche Grosseltern.
Ihre vier Kinder und deren Partner
sind alle berufstätig.
Aufenthalte bei Oma und Opa
sind fester Bestandteil
des Betreuungskonzeptes.
Oh, Sie haben aber Dinge im Wagen,
die Sie verzollen müssen.
Das reicht nur knapp.
Adieu.
Grüezi, wohin gehen Sie?
Ein Vulkan ist ausgebrochen?
Dann müssen Sie sofort hin.
Aber es kostet trotzdem.
Ja. Es gibt noch Wechselgeld.
So. Also, gute Fahrt.
Oh, Sie! Sie müssen
eine Kurve machen, hinten anstellen.
Adieu.
Manchmal denke ich ...
Mal wie viel ist es?
Hoch 10? Hoch 12?
Wir erleben ...
Ich muss von mir reden:
Ich erlebe sehr viel Freude.
Ganz stark.
Es sind viele Kinder.
Wir teilen mit den Kindern
die ganze Freude.
Aber auch mit allen Kindern -
zumindest mit unseren - die Sorgen.
Es ist ein Auf und Ab.
Es ist wie Wüste und Paradies
zusammen.
Walter und Brigitte Hollenstein
heirateten jung
und wollten ganz viele Kinder haben.
Wir sprachen
von einem halben Dutzend.- Genau.
Wir haben es aber trotzdem
auf vier reduziert.
Wir stiessen schon an Grenzen.
Mit vieren
war das Mass richtig voll.
Und die Ressourcen waren ...
beschränkt.
Nach vieren sagten wir,
jetzt reiche es.
Kinder zu haben
braucht sehr viel Energie.
Bei den Enkeln
haben wir eine 1:1-Betreuung.
Es ist nicht mehr
wie bei den eigenen Kindern,
wo nebenher
der Haushalt gemacht werden muss.
Sondern es ist eine 1:1-Betreuung.
Abends sind wir dann müde.
Das ist Qualität:
Wir können sie wieder abgeben,
ohne die volle Verantwortung
zu haben.
Andererseits
haben wir auch mehr Lebenserfahrung.
Darum wissen wir, dass gewisse Dinge
wieder vorbeigehen.
Phasen gehen vorbei.
Das ist die Trotzphase.
Das ist nun einfach so.
Aber wir wissen, dass andere kommen.
Das ist Erfahrung.
* Entspannte Jazzmusik *
Könnt ihr mir helfen runtertragen?
Kinder haben heisst auch verzichten -
auf Freizeit, Schlaf,
Zeit mit dem Partner
oder die berufliche Karriere.
Kinder
realisieren dies in der Regel erst,
wenn sie selber Eltern geworden sind.
Auswärts essen
gehen wir eh nicht mehr.
Das tun wir uns nicht an.
Grundsätzlich
spüren wir Dankbarkeit.
Einerseits dass es unsere Kinder
so gut haben mit den Grosseltern.
Und mit den Schwiegergrosseltern.
Andererseits auch Dankbarkeit
für diese Selbstverständlichkeit,
die wir selber als Kinder
gespürt haben.
Wenn man Dinge haben wollte,
wenn die Eltern
mit uns etwas unternommen haben.
Jetzt merken wir,
wie viel Aufwand das bedeutet.
Meine Eltern hatten vier Kinder -
noch mehr als unsere drei Kinder.
Aber man lernt es zu schätzen
und dankbar zu sein,
für das,
was sie für uns geopfert haben.
Jetzt geben wir es gerne weiter,
weil wir uns an diese
schönen Momente zurückerinnern.
"'Nicht jetzt', sagt der Hase.
'Ich grabe ein wichtiges Loch.'"
"Zack ist er aus dem Bild."
"'Wow, das könnte funktionieren.'
Und sie springen aufeinander zu."
"Dann umarmen sie sich,
rollen herum
und sind überglücklich."
Man vergisst so schnell,
was war.
Man ist in der Dichte des Alltags
und macht und tut.
Man ist auch viel jünger.
Ich glaube,
es ist auch ein Funktionieren.
Aber ein Funktionieren, das
immer wieder Aufsteller beinhaltet.
Diese ganze Dichte im Kinder haben
würde einen zugrunde richten,
wenn es dazwischen nicht immer
wieder Glücksmomente geben würde.
* Entspannte Jazzmusik *
Wenn die Kinder erwachsen sind,
erinnert man sich an die Kinder.
Dann werden die Kinder
für die meisten zum Glücksfaktor.
Auch durch selektives Vergessen.
Man erinnert sich nur noch
an die schönen Momente.
Im Nachhinein sieht man, dass es
tatsächlich einen Einfluss hat:
Menschen, die Kinder hatten,
sind im Allgemeinen glücklicher,
als solche ohne -
aber erst im Nachhinein.
* Verspielte Klänge *
Wir sind wieder
bei Sabina und Roger Rhyner.
Für euch ist die Antwort
auf die Frage
"Machen Kinder glücklich?" klar.
Ihr sagt:
- Ja. Ganz klar.
Ein Leben ohne sie
wäre unvorstellbar.
Das ist so.
Ihr habt so viel auf euch genommen,
um die Kinder zu bekommen.
Wissen sie, auf welchem besonderen
Weg sie zu euch gekommen sind?
Indirekt.
- Indirekt, ja.
Wann gehen wir nach draussen?
- Wir müssen erst etwas erzählen.
Indirekt durch eine Geschichte.
"Die Königin und der König
sind überglücklich."
"Nach einer langen Zeit
wünschen sie sich ein Baby."
Sari, wo ist das Baby?
"Sie gehen zum Doktor, weil
die Königin nicht schwanger wird."
"Der Doktor
kann ihnen aber nicht helfen."
"Er hat aber eine Idee. In Spanien
gibt es Doktor Wuschelkopf."
"Dieser kann ihnen helfen."
"Sie fliegen mit dem Flugzeug ..."
wohin?
Zu Doktor Wuschelkopf.
- Genau.
Doktor Wuschelkopf. Aha.
Lio,
was kann Doktor Wuschelkopf machen?
Zeigst du es?
- In Spanien.- Er ist in Spanien.
Ah ja. Und was kann er machen?
Ein Baby.
Aha, er kann ein Baby machen.
Er hilft der Königin.
Dann fliegen sie wieder nach Hause,
und sie ist schwanger.
Jetzt haben wir keine Bilder mehr.
Dabei beginnt hier das Familienleben
erst so richtig.
Ja. Am Schluss sage ich immer: "Das
ist eure Geschichte, Lio und Sari."
Das ist der Schluss.
Denkt ihr, dass er später,
wenn er älter wird,
das Bedürfnis haben wird, seine
"genetischen Eltern" kennenzulernen?
Wird das ein Thema?
- Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich auch nicht. Je besser
wir es machen, desto weniger.
Aber das wird sich zeigen.
- Wir lassen es auf uns zukommen.
Wir können es nicht beeinflussen,
nur gute Eltern sein.
Wir geben unser Bestes.
Alles andere ist ihre Entscheidung.
Ihr lasst es auf euch zukommen.
Wir wünschen euch alles Gute.
Vielen Dank,
dass ihr so offen geredet habt.
Danke auch.
Weiter geht es auf SRF 1
mit einem Film,
in dem es um Kinder haben geht.
Es ist aber
eine spezielle Freundschaft.
Mathias Gnädinger in der Hauptrolle
im Film "Der Grosse Sommer".
Vielen Dank fürs Interesse,
einen schönen Abend.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Sabine Näpflin - 2020